vaud
point de vue en particulier sur cette
mesure qui vous fait énormément réagir
depuis ce matin qui vous fait réagir
notamment sur les réseaux l'interdiction
définitive des animaux sauvages dans les
cirques et la fermeture annoncée des
delphinariums notamment la protection du
bien-être animal
va-t-elle trop loin ça c'est la question
dont on va débattre avec notamment
dominique reynié bonjour dominique vous
êtes directeur général de la fondapol et
on signale bien ça tombe bien que la
fondapol avait édité une paix une
brochure sur 7 sur cette question la
contestation animal radical c'est donc à
la fondapol dg et de eddy fougier
effectivement également on vient de le
voir votre dernière note l'europe la
transition bas carbone du bon usage de
la souveraineté
on en débat également avec alexis brézet
bonjour à les bourgeois directeur des
rédactions du figaro le figaro qui fait
sa une demain sur les universités
grandes écoles la rentrée le coc vide le
grand bazar tout ça alors dominique
reynié face alexis à braiser c'est un
peu rodez contre montréjeau le nord de
l'occitanie contre le sud mais c'est un
débat qu'on n'aura pas ce soir mais on
pourra la voir
une autre fois ce soir je vous propose
en revanche de revenir en revanche sur
le cac dupont moretti peut-il tenir à ce
poste on attend vos points de vue mais
d'abord donc cette première question
qu'on pose sur le site du figaro fauve
dauphin approuvez-vous l'interdiction
programmée des spectacles d'animaux
c'est la question qu'on pose depuis ce
matin sur le site du figaro et vous êtes
très nombreux à répondre et à répondre
pour l'instant oui on le rappelle cette
mesure a été annoncée par la ministre la
transit de l'environnement de la
transition écologique
barbara pompili on l'écoutait fauves un
éléphant singes dauphins ou encore
visant
il est temps d'ouvrir une nouvelle ère
dans notre rapport à ces animaux il est
temps que notre fascination ancestrales
pour ces êtres sauvages ne se traduise
plupart des situations
on favorise leur captivité par rapport à
leur bien-être
notre époque a changé elle est celle
d'un rapport nouveau à l'animal sauvage
bien plus qu'une menace ou qu'une proie
il est désormais avant tout et c'est ma
conviction profonde
un être à préserver et à respecter
alors parmi les professions visé il y a
les deux mille cinq cents éleveurs de
visons ils protestent et leurs porte
paroles notamment s'est rebiffé on
écoute prennent aux échanges ce n'est
pas pour des questions de maltraitance
animale car il n'y a pas de cas de
maltraitance animale mais c'est en
revanche poursuivre une lame de fond et
nous estimons que cette fausse opinion
c'est une lame de fond animalistes qui
s'attaque à l'élevage et à la ruralité
et cela va entraîner en france une perte
de près de 2500 emplois dans la fourrure
car les acteurs se sentiront menacé et
vont devoir délocaliser dans des pays
plus accueillants et plus tolérant
dominique reynié vous êtes sensible à sa
protestation des éleveurs de visons ou
bien vous êtes plutôt du côté de 17 57
cent cinquante mille internautes qui ont
voté avec le soutien des 141
parlementaire en faveur d'un référendum
d'initiative partagée pour la condition
animale qui demande notamment la mesure
qui a été prise par barbara pompidou
mais il faut toujours ces sujets là
enfin moi je trouve qu'il faut toujours
avoir un point de vue équilibré parce
que il se trouve que la cause animale
qui a sa légitimité notamment en ce qui
concerne les problèmes de maltraitance
qui font l'objet d'ailleurs de loi en
france depuis 1850 pour la première fois
la loi grammont sous napoléon iii donc
c'est quelque chose qui a toute une
histoire
et ça ça tombe sous le sens je pense de
chacun par contre il ya aussi des
secteurs économiques on l'a entendu ici
où il n'ya pas de maltraitance mais
c'est d'élevage qui est visé
ou qui sont des secteurs à la fois
porteur de d'une richesse économique
mais aussi parfois de traditions locales
et je trouve que dans le discours de la
ministre mais ce n'est pas la première
fois se déploie à travers ses propos et
même ses décisions une forme de
dogmatisme qu'elle porte avec une
certaine assurance et qui nous amène à
nous interroger sur la raison de ce
discours c'est dieu veut dire par là
à quel moment ça m'a échappé à quel
moment depuis 2010 est on a voté pour un
pouvoir de ce type pour un discours de
ce type là sur l'élevage avant sur les
betteraviers c'est toute une vision qui
est qui qui sont la conviction dit elle
de la ministre m'enfin c'est pas tout à
fait ça une politique démocratique il ya
quand même des élections tour du lieu et
je n'ai pas vu que sets ça faisait
partie des éléments dans le programme
adopté alors c'est pas une politique
démocratique va nous dire dominique
reynié ceci dit quand on voit la réponse
à la question qui est posée au fil sur
le site du figaro on voit que pas mal de
gens sont favorables à cette mesure
louis nous disent par exemple
l'interdiction et progressive limité aux
animaux sauvages cohérente avec les
inadaptés l'inadaptabilité à la
captivité de ces espèces est donc
légitime sa rencontre néanmoins un écho
dans l'opinion ni cui parce qu'on vit
une mutation sociologique
extraordinairement profonde
philosophique vie par rapport à l'animal
ray souffrance animale au bien-être
animal et c'est que certains écologistes
radicaux antisexiste voudrait prolonger
une sorte de bascule anthropologique se
dire que il ya d'abord le point de
départ qui la souffrance et bien-être et
là je pense et demi que je disais ça
date pas d'hier
et évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
sur le soufre la question de ne pas
souffrir les bêtes et on est le
bien-être animal c'est important les
minimales sont doués d'une sensibilité
et donc de ce point de vue la question
de savoir si le lion pauvres lions qui
tourne dans sa pauvre cage indéfiniment
il faut le laisser
je comprends que ça puisse se discute et
on a tous ces souvenirs la deux
du petit cirque avec le lion qui tourne
comme un lion en cage en se balançant la
tête et on sent qu'ils sont qui sont un
peu dingo est quelque chose de gênant
mais donc là je comprends que ça se
discute et je comprends aussi que le
malheureux dompteur à qui on dit vous
allez vous transformer en cirque du
soleil est monté sur des échasses avec
des plumes dans derrière lui dit mais
non moi je suis docteur donc moi j'ai
entendu des gens dire maintenant il ya
des cirques
il ya d'autres cirques sans animaux mais
c'est pas les mêmes cirque donc c'est
pas les mêmes métiers du cirque mais ça
je comprends que ça se discute et qu'on
puisse avoir mais ce qui me paraît
frappant et je rejoins ce que ce que dit
dominique c'est que ya derrière une idée
de bascule anthropologique qui va
beaucoup plus loin que le bien-être et
la souffrance c'est me semble-t-il
l'idée qu'on s'est fait depuis des
millénaires de civilisation
judéo-chrétienne notre quitter les grecs
les romains jusqu'aux lumières qui
l'idée que l'homme était le centre de la
création et donc avait vocation à régner
sur la création et sur les animaux en
les respectant en s'insérant dedans non
pas un saccage en mai mais que malgré
tout il avait une sorte de légitimité a
dominé la création et là on entre dans
une vision philosophique que je ne
partage pas mais qui a sa cohérence qui
veut dire mais non l'homme est un animal
comme les autres y a pas plus de droits
que les autres
il n'y a pas de raison qu'on impose quoi
que ce soit un animal est donc
aujourd'hui on nous dit les tigres et
des lions les dauphins mais demain on
nous dira pas ce qu'on dit c'est pas
normal qu'un éléphant monte sur un
tabouret c'est vrai on n'a jamais vu un
éléphant
mais demain nous dira les chevaux les
chevaux dans la nature ils portent pas
des gens sur leur dos les vaches dans la
nature ont les traits ne se passe pas
dans des trieuses automatique et les
chiens ils conduisent pas des aveugles
donc l'idée qu'il ya derrière ça au fond
et elle me paraît extrêmement dangereuse
parce que c'est un surcoût c'est un anti
humanisme c'est l'idée de dire que
l'homme n'est plus au centre delà de la
création et que l'homme est un animal
peut être un peu plus malin que les
autres mais finalement pas supérieur aux
autres et ça nous amène et je pense
qu'on est qu'au début de cette évolution
kim sommes varient très dangereuse
philosophiquement cesser
c'est pareil vous fait la même analyse
et est ce que vous partagez la même
inquiétude il ya toute une tradition
philosophique solide sur la question de
la condition animale depuis plus tard
que d'ailleurs jusqu'aujourd'hui il ya
de grands débats philosophiques
passionnant et très solide sur le sujet
avec des auteurs qui sont qui sont
vraiment très très fameux pas les citer
mais enfin tome reagan en particulier a
beaucoup écrit là-dessus mais là on est
dans autre chose au fond parce que ces
interrogations sont sont nécessaires
elles font partie des questions que nous
nous posons et où il ya des aménagements
qui sont indispensables mais là on est
dans autre chose et ce qui me frappe
c'est que on voit à travers ses
revendications n'ont pas la sensibilité
à la maltraitance animale
nous sommes tous un consensus attend
consensus allez on est tous effrayés par
ces personnes qui qui torturent des
chevaux régulièrement et où cet abattoir
est absolument hors d'ici là là ça tombe
sous le sens si on est tous de près mais
la question c'est de savoir ce que ça
n'est pas une sorte de moi j'y vois un
combat contre l'économie la création de
richesses l'activité humaine sous un
drapeau qui est beaucoup plus
présentable que le drapeau précédent qui
était au fond portée dans une sorte
d'anti capitalisme très à gauche et qui
maintenant c'est un muté parce que les
partis sont plus là parce que l'urss des
plus là et devient cette espèce de
revendications systématiquement hostiles
à ces modalités les productions mais
faut juste a ajouté que je rappelle ce
sont des courants idéologiques qui n'ont
aucune puissance électorale parce qu'il
faut quand même le rappeler comment pour
opérer une telle bascule sans puissance
électorale par des groupes de pression
par des pétitions en agissant sur les
gouvernants sans avoir le pouvoir
un pardon quand même en s'appuyant sur
une évolution des sensibilités des
urbains qui n'ont plus de lien avec la
campagne et qu'ils disent
bon ben là mais est bête sauvage ça va
de soi parce qu'on a vu à la télévision
le lion de daktari mais mais mais qui va
finir par dire qu'on n'a plus le droit
finalement d'exploiter les animaux parce
qu'au fond on a parlé de on est en train
d'inventer le concept de l'exploitation
de l'animal par l'homme qui devient
quelque chose de condamnable en soi et
de l'or va finir par daigné même le
concept même de nature humaine
c'est ça au fond qui est derrière ces la
cotation de l'idée de nature humaine
donc donc ça s'appuie comme ce quelque
chose d'assez fort moi je dirais pas
qu'il n'y a pas de mouvement que c'est
juste quelques militants je pense qu'à
une mutation de nos sensibilités qui par
certains côtés s'appuie sur des choses
qu après tout on peut respecter mais que
certains essaient d'entrer nebbou au
delà vers une constation radical qui va
bien plus loin que la concession d'un
modèle économique ça serait ça serait
déjà préoccupant mais un modèle de
civilisation que sur sur l'absence de
socle électoral vous
vous dites ça dominique mais on a quand
même vu au moment des élections
européennes que le score du parti
animalistes avait dépassé toutes les
prévisions qui avait été fait même s'il
restait mineurs de mémoire aux alentours
de 2% oui il ya bien sûr une expression
électorale qui mais qui est marginal qui
est très marginal mais ce dernier que
c'est que les écoliers sont pas gagné
les élections municipales
mais pour les minispaces à ses sujets et
oui c'est ça que vous voulez favoris ils
sont meilleurs et l'air c'est pour la
gagner
il ne fait aucun doute sur les villes de
plus de 20 mille habitants ils n'en
n'ont que douze la droite en a presque
300 et le ps 140 n'y a pas de doute là
dessus ce sont des données mais
simplement mais vous ne voyez pas de
lien justement dans le fait que la
ministre prenne cette décision après la
présélection minutie mollahs et après
les élections sénatoriales d'ailleurs
moi je pense qu'elle veut crantée
qu'elle veut imposer toute une série de
décisions qui nous font entrer dans une
société qui n'a pas été choisi et des
sans avoir le soutien des suffrages
donc on est à la fois dans la sortie
d'un rapport à la création de richesse
que l'on commence à mettre en cause en
tant que telle est la sortie d'un modèle
démocratique par des revendications qui
sont qui sont exprimés avec la force
d'une conviction
ok mais sans avoir pris le soin d'en
mesurer le rationnement électorale on a
vu donc la dimension anthropologique la
dimension politique également dans cette
dans cette affaire vous évoquez
également une dimension économique
vous disiez c'est une nouvelle forme
d'anticapitalisme vous êtes d'accord
avec ce point de vue là le site oui
puisqu'ils ont fini il ya un lien
2 comment dire de continuer de
continuité entre l'exploitation de
l'homme par l'homme et l'exploitation de
l'animal par l'homme et donc c'est tout
ce qui est ce qui est utilisé l'animal
pour produire quelque chose devient une
contestation du modèle de production et
donc on va remettre en cause d'abord les
conditions inhumaines animal d'élevage
des animaux puis de là l'élevage tout
court des animaux parce que là on nous
dit les visions puis demain nous dira
les poules il n'y a pas de raison que
une poule est pas plus heureuse dans une
cage qu'un visant alors on va nous dire
focaliser des grandes cages mais en fait
à la fin on dira mais de toute façon une
poule c'est pas fait pour être traité
comme ça parce que et on va nous dire
même chose pour les vaches sion
j'entends des médicaments qui décide si
on pouvait très un petit peu la vache
mais pas trop lui prendre son relais
puis pas lui arracher son veau bon
d'accord mais c'est ça c'est ça l'idée
qu'à derrière je vous pose la question
sur le plan économique parce que on voit
quand même que en tout cas dans le
soutien à l'initiative lancée donc par
le journaliste hugot clément donc d'un
référendum d'initiative partagée
on voit quand même des stars du business
français du business le plus moderne
on le voit notamment jacques antoine
grandjean le créateur de vente privée et
marc simoncini l'homme de meetic xavier
niel ce sont aussi des entrepreneurs des
anticapitalistes non non mais là il faut
voir quand même alors il ya beaucoup
d'ignorance pour moi dans ses prises de
position il ya beaucoup d'ignorance
il ya aussi un marché c'est le marché du
steak végétal pardon de le dire bien sûr
qu'ils aient fait principalement d'eau
il faut il faut ajouter et qui se vend
au prix du steak donc c'est une
opération sans jeu de mots juteuse et
puis moi je ne sais pas où nous conduire
qui s'intéressent à william intérêts de
secteurs quand même on est en train de
créer une nouvelle filière qui est celle
du steak végétales et les opérateurs de
la filière un soutiennent avec des
moyens importants
ce référendum d'initiative donc partager
donc ces pardons de faire le lien mais
ne pas de ne pas le faire serait une
faute
c'est l'un des reproches faites
notamment par la fnsea oui mais c'est
très surprenant
imaginons un référendum sur l'élevage
porté par des éleveurs on dirait
attendez vous rigolez ben oui c'est ce
qui se passe ce sont des éleveurs de
steak végétaux si je puis dire ou
cultivateurs je sais pas ce qu'il faut
dire il met du soja et on sait pas si
c'est pas transgénique
c'était une grande confusion tout ça et
puis moi je me demande je pose une
question un peu embarrassante mais quand
même
est ce que cette se soucie de l'animal
va aller jusqu'à interdire la corrida
est ce que ça va la réussite est
effectivement il ya cet internaute qui
nous dit-il série dia qui nous dit ces
gens qui mutilent des chevaux aurait dû
devenir toréador comme ça ils auraient
pu servir leurs pulsions cruelle en
étant applaudi et payé pour est-ce que
ça va jusqu'à interdire l'abattage
religieux alors ça c'est une autre
question effectivement d'un internaute
qui dit on parle de tigre qui vivent
pour la plupart très bien quid des
moutons égorgés le rite religieux et
donc la question est ce qu'il ya une
cohérence dans cette radicalité la
radicalité doit être cohérente si spider
disponibles on déploie tout l'arsenal de
l'interdiction et on va aller jusqu'à
interdire les rites religieux ou bien
est ce que en réalité on s'arrête au
visant parce qu'on a une espèce de
d'objectif politique dogmatique mais
sans aller sur des terres que l'on ne
veut pas visité parce que on a d'autres
positions par ailleurs c'est cette
espèce de d'absence de cohérence de
logique de fermeté dans le jugement et
la décision qui montre qui je dirais
qu'il en montre le fondement
anticapitaliste d'un côté et puis en
même temps très politique de l'autre et
sont des éléments qui vont évidemment
éclaté au grand jour
je crois qu'il ya 2
deux types d'acteurs dans ce genre de
débat il ya les politiques qui sont plus
circonspects qui je poursuis
effectivement des intérêts électoraux
macron c'est embringué dans son affaire
de convention citoyenne pour l'écologie
il est bien embêté parce que maintenant
il faut donner des gages et donc on lui
dit qu'on va interdire la publicité pour
les automobilistes qui auraient même
temps je le secteur automobile qui est
en train de se casser la figure qu'est
ce que je fais on le dit qu'on va
interdire les voyages en avion et zioui
bêtes à cornes le secteur aéronautique
qui se casse la figure qu'est ce que je
fais bon là on lui dit qu'on va
interdire les lions dans les cas j'ai
dit bon bah ça c'est pas trop difficile
et est du coup là il ya un intérêt
politique évident de ne pas paraître aux
yeux de l'opinion des couches moyennes
supérieures urbaine comme porteur de
dinde et à l'environnemental
donc ça c'est ça c'est la classique et
je pense que complice s'inscrit là
dedans il ya de la politique d'ailleurs
après il ya des vrais idéologues qui
sont derrière tout ça qui est
passionnant un projet beaucoup plus
radicale beaucoup plus fondamentale qui
dans certains s'en sont peut-être plus
honnête mais plus me semble-t-il plus
dangereux et qui eux vous dirai oui à
toutes les petites ou tout ce que vous
avez proposé qu'il faut interdire les
corridas évidemment l'abattage rituel et
tout et tout et est donc ça c'est un
projet et parce que là il ya un projet
de civilisation anthropologique donc
c'est une vraie idéologie qui en train
de remplacer les idéologies anciennes et
le marxisme etc
c'est l'idéologie de la terre mère et de
l'homme qui est un petit élément mieux
tout ça qui ne fait que passer qui sera
remplacé de main pas autre chose et que
d'ailleurs qu'ils n'avaient pas dire une
grande valeur parce que ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que plus on réévaluer
la valeur de l'animal puisons d'évaluer
la valeur de l'homme et on peut le tuer
au début avant qu'il naisse et on peut
le tuer après avant qu'il meure ça c'est
pas si grave parce que finalement c'est
jamais en tout cas c'est en sûrement pas
plus grave que de manger un oeuf puisque
finalement à qu'est ce que c'est on va
et donc oui il ya une espèce de mettre
l'homme sur le même plan que l'animal
dans un espèce de globalité
philosophique donc cela oui cela ils
veulent tout ils veulent tout et au delà
les autres il fonda politique les amis
des animaux entre lucas sont très
présents souvent dans d'autres dans
notre débat de savoir que pendant que
vous parliez la nautique cia lui nous
dit la notion de plaisir dans la corrida
est insupportable on l'a compris que
vous étiez contre mais abattre un animal
pour se nourrir et du fer le journal a
supprimé la corrida il y aura plus un
seul taureau de nulle part parce que les
et oloron les élèves pour ça les
taureaux de combat on les élève pas pour
pour faire des veaux on les aide pour
combattre
donc il y aura plutôt comme ça ils
seront heureux mais nous n'existerons
plus d'un minot qui vous dit j'entends
ce que dit alexis brézet mais je pense
que les militants spéciste restent très
minoritaires au sein de la population
française
oui cela mais l'aspiration écologique lé
pa moin lé peut-être minoritaire mais
elle est largement répandue ce qui est
quand même étonnant on peut ajouter ça
aussi parce que c'est moi moi
personnellement je n'ai aucun goût pour
les animaux de cirque je trouve ça
douloureux avoir pénible enfin vraiment
qu'est ce que je fais je n'y vais pas et
ce qui me frappe quand même c'est dans
un pays mûrs qu'il y ait cette idée
d'interdire d'aller assister à des
spectacles qui peut être vont simplement
disparaître parce qu'en réalité je ne
crois pas que la sphère était était
florissante et nous tous peu à peu en
fait on n'a cessé d'y aller on nous y
amener est en france nous a pas vraiment
plu on y retourne plus on n'amène pas
nos enfants
enfin bref c'est aussi une façon de
suivre une société qui est souvent un
serpent que oui non le voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est voilà là c'est quand
même
une vision madame pompili va s'assurer
que nous n'aurions nous n'aurons pas le
droit de faire ce qui ne correspond pas
à ses convictions profondes
je n'aime pas cette société là et je
préfère encore une société qui peu à peu
se désintéresse des animaux de cirque à
une société où depuis paris et un poste
ministériel
on va nous interdire telle ou telle
pratique parce que c'est rare earth la
conviction et les convictions de la
ministre y est le tour de france et les
arbres et tout passe et tout un pas
absolument on à la séquence nostalgie
donc avec pascal qui nous dit je viens
de voir avec stupeur que l'on va
interdire la présence des animaux
sauvages dans les cirques va-t-on
supprimer des centaines d'années d'us et
coutumes alors en revanche france
animaux dudit un animal domestique n'a
rien à faire en liberté et consommer de
la viande ou du sujet a le même ou du
soja a le même impact écologique
on vous posez la question donc on vous
pose la question et vous pouvez
continuer à voter sur le site du figaro
fauves dauphin alors on n'a pas parlé
des dauphins également et de la
fermeture des delphinariums ça je ne
sais pas si vous connaissiez mais j'ai
découvert le l'exploit le terme de
delphine a brillamment crib et anti
effectivement et jean leonetti qui est
en colère d'ailleurs contre le délai qui
est accordée le trop peu de délai selon
lui qui est accordée donc fauves de faim
approuvez-vous l'interdiction programmée
des spectacles d'animaux sauvages et
pour l'instant vous êtes une large
majorité à répondre oui près de 61% vous
pouvez continuer à voter
l'autre question qu'on vous pose elle
concerne eric dupond moretti
peut-il tenir cet après midi le ministre
de la justice l'a assuré il est allé
chercher les augmentations budgétaires
avec les dents et effectivement le
budget de la justice est l'un des
gagnants du budget
2021 + 8% à 8 2 milliards d'euros
vous allez avoir tous les détails dans
les prochaines heures avec les
précisions de paul gonzalez qui est la
spécialiste justice au figaro
apparemment ceci dit il en faut plus
pour calmer les magistrats les plus
prestigieux d'entre eux montent au
créneau françois menaces notamment et
chantal arens cet après midi ses
empreintes dans une tribune à la
nomination par le garde des sceaux
d'abord d'une avocate à la tête de
l'école nationale de la magistrature
c'était de l'an dernier et surtout à
l'intervention du ministre dans un
dossier qui le concernent qui est celui
des coûts de téléphonie et lui avaient
été en tout cas ces relevés
téléphoniques ont été épluchés par des
magistrats s'étaient on a découvert la
sphère au mois de juin dernier et il
avait saisi après plusieurs étapes dans
l' enquête l'inspection générale des
services pour une enquête administrative
à l'encontre de trois magistrats du
parquet national financiers ce qui
soulève là la phrase suivante de la part
de françois molins et challes chantal
arens les magistrats sont légitimement
inquiet de la situation dans laquelle
l'institution se trouve depuis que le
garde des sceaux saisi l'inspection
générale de la justice d'une enquête
administrative contre trois magistrats
du pnl chargé d'une procédure qu'il
avait concerné le conflit d'intérêts que
sous tend cette situation ne peut
qu'inquiéter alors cette tribune
intervient cinq jours après une
manifestation des magistrats avec en
pointe
le syndicat de la magistrature on écoute
il y avait des inquiétudes au départ on
a essayé de dialoguer que le garde des
sceaux maintenant la confiance est
rompue il faut immédiatement arrêter
mettre fin à cette inspection et
recevoir les organisations syndicales
pour pouvoir commencer à parler d'abord
des remontées d'informations qui sont
aussi un autre une autre préoccupation
qu'on peut avoir les remontées
d'informations dans les enquêtes en
cours
quel est le périmètre de ce qui remonte
aux ministres et ensuite de commencer à
parler réellement de réformes de fond
alors voici ce qu avait répondu ce jour
là est bien le ministre l'expression
syndicale
voilà les seuls à s'exprimer moi je suis
un démocrate convaincu les syndicats
disent ce qu'ils ont envie de dire et
moi je dis aussi ce que j'ai envie de
dire
alexis eric dupond-moretti dit notamment
dans la sphère du concert avec le pnf
qu'il a cherché à mettre les formes
et tout le monde plus ou moins le
reconnais mais rhétoriquement on peut
dire qu'il n'est pas les formes
vis-à-vis des magistrats avant
d'examiner sa faut quand même voir la
gravité de la situation le la première
présidente de la cour de cassation le
progrès après la colocation c'est les
deux au plus haut magistrat de france
qui explique que le ministre garde des
sceaux leur ministre de tutelle garant
de l'indépendance de la justice et est
coupable est sous le coup d'une
accusation de conflit d'intérêts c'est
pas de la rigolade
c'est comme si je peux le chef
d'état-major des armées jeu notamment
jean marc est terne l'armée de terre
expliquait que le que le mes de la
défense est coupable de haute trahison
enfin ça c'est les deux plus hauts
fonctionnaires de la justice qui
conteste publiquement dans une tribune
dans un quotidien leur ministre donc ces
quelques c'est une situation qui est
absolument gravissime alors après on va
dire oui peut-être qu'ils aient pas fait
ce qu'il fallait dans la façon de
s'exprimer et c'est après malgré tout
derrière me semble qu'il ya un espèce
d'immense corporatisme l'arrêter c'est
quoi tout le monde sait que le parc
national financier s'est affranchi da
semblerait qu il ya une enquête
administrative qui l'établît qu'ils ont
écouté la terre entière pour essayer de
rattraper sarkozy dans une histoire sans
d'ailleurs y arriver et que donc ils
sont mais coûteux de la moitié des
avocats de paris des journalistes dont
une journée de figaro ce qui est
absolument illégal donc tout le monde
sait qu'ils ont fait ça parmi les gens
qui sont aux côtés il ya dupond moretti
bon avant que dupont moretti arif
belloubet me garde des sceaux contre le
parquet national financier déclenché une
enquête du congrès qui reçoit l'en quête
dans lequel il écrit noir sur blanc à
l'or noir sur blanc non parce que quand
c'est justice qui enquête sur la justice
c'est gris sur gris
m'enfin on comprend quand même que ils
ont exagéré que la loyauté a peut être
entièrement respectées que la france est
actionné en dysfonctionnement il ya
quand même une question de loyauté et
des soignants et donc n'importe quel
ministre sur la base de cette enquête
aurait fait ce café dupond moretti s'est
déclenché une enquête administrative sur
les magistrats en question qui est le
premier pas vers une procédure
disciplinaire
le problème c'est que du bri il est dans
la sphère peut-être que deux
sa chance est il aurait pu ne pas le
faire mais bon il dit après tout un
autre comment elle aurait fait je le
fais pauvres et donc là dessus tout le
monde monte au créneau en disant pas
touche au parquet national financier pas
touche aux magistrats on n'a pas le
droit dans ce pays de toucher aux
magistrats cela dit c'est compliqué
maintenant pour dupont moretti j'aurai
tout ça je fasse je le concède mais le
l'espèce de de réaction corporatiste de
cette profession ce jour et c'est ce
qu'on regarde un peu ce qui se passe
dans leur malheur petits secrets
pareil quand même assez extraordinaire
une réaction corporatiste tony cousin
oui moi je ne suis pas j'ai pas de
compétence sur ce dossier en particulier
c'est frappant de voir en tout cas les
magistrats réagir de cette manière là
quand leur propre situation est en
question assez être assez muet sur ou
plutôt tout à fait muet d'ailleurs sur
d'autres problèmes qui touchent à la
justice son inefficacité par exemple dès
qu'ils les laissent de marbre
il faut pas oublier de donner raison au
ministre sur l'augmentation tellement
nécessaire du budget de la justice est
lui pour cent si c'est confirmé c'est ce
n'est pas un rattrapage mais c'est un
progrès sensible et donc je trouve que
les magistrats pourraient pour le coup
ça lui mais ça quand même au lieu de
rompre et c'est fait pour ça c'est une
façon de faire mais je pense que là la
position du ministre la justice elle est
faible mais aussi parce que sur l'aspect
plus voilà sur l'aspect qui est plus en
rapport à l'opinion son rapport à la
justice là je crois que il fait courir
des risques au président de la
république s'il imagine que cet attelage
darmanin moretti va la mener qu'à un cas
à hue et à dia à droite à gauche jusqu'à
il me semble que cette partie là de
l'attelage est quand même très faible
parce qu'il y a de très gros problèmes
de sécurité
et ça c'est aussi du côté de la justice
que ça pêche oui moi je veux dire que
sur le fond du dossier enfin vous l'avez
bien compris je pense que sur le fond de
ces peines a fui la raison de noter
faire il n'en reste pas moins que
politiquement il se met en situation de
grande fragilité pour une région qui
rejoint ce que vient de dire dominique
c'est à dire que
vis-à-vis de l'opinion il endosse là
contre l'opinion et contre le sentiment
de l'opinion idf1 les juges la totalité
des français sont absolument persuadé
que la justice est laxiste que les
petits délinquants ne font pas leur
peine et c'est pas faux et que les ce
que que subban et à l'euro de lourdes
peines en faut mieux la madame moitié
bon et donc il ya dans l'opinion le
sentiment que la justice n'est pas assez
sévère et la dupond-moretti prend à
revers l'opinion il défend les juges
mais par ailleurs il attaque les juges
sur cette affaire du parc et de
financiers le résultat me semble
hidoussa c'est qu'il se met en situation
d'être que l'opinion 10 mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce garde des sceaux qui
fait moins comme tous les autres il va
par israël seront pas plus sévères pour
ce qu'attend les qu'attendent les
français c'est par les espoirs de parc
national financier c'est une justice
qu'ils jugent sévèrement rapidement
efficacement les petits délits et donc
la i10 bassil les défenses il dit que
c'est bien ça veut dire que ça va
changer
et de l'autre côté il a contrôlé un
magistrat pour les mots toutes les
mauvaises raisons qu'on a dit mais si on
a contre soi et l'opinion les magistrats
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
politiquement je sentais ce que nous dit
un peu let's entités restent avocats ne
pas vouloir voir la réalité
je pense que c'était concernant le
sentiment de sécurité est là comme
l'intrigué manque de sécurité c'est plus
grave que l'insécurité
ça c'est pas le meilleur moyen d'être
populaire dans tous les cas les
magistrats par contre nous dit alex ne
rendent pas compte au peuple au nom
duquel l'iran de la justice et c'est
problématique donc peut-être que dans
cette fronde avec les magistrats il peut
peut-être avoir un soutien de l'opinion
oui mais il faudrait qu'il prenne ça
autrement c'est à dire que depuis le
début c'est encore possible mais on est
entendu dire ça ne va pas la justice ne
punit pas assez vite assez sévèrement et
de manière efficiente
comme il a été dit moi je voudrais
insister sur ce point quand même parce
que la non application des peines ou la
libération très anticipée
deux personnes qui devraient rester en
prison ça une conséquence extrêmement
grave ça signifie que la transgression
ne fait pas l'objet de la punition qui
est prévu et qui est attendu par la
société et c'est ça la justice est pas
punir le coupable seulement c'est à dire
à la société que la règle existe et
qu'on ne peut pas la transgresser c'est
à dire c'est refaire société et rassurer
tout le monde sur l'existence de la
règle si on doute de l'existence de la
règle ce qui va se passer c'est qu'il y
aura une privatisation de la justice et
donc c'est un défaut marie l'utilisation
d'un ça signifie qu'on n'a plus
confiance dans la justice du pays et
donc on va commencer à se dire qu'il
faut se débrouiller compter sur soi-même
c'est un processus qui est à l'oeuvre
dans notre société
je suis étonné que le ministre de la
justice mais par la voix la société le
sentiment que la police fait ce qu'elle
peut mais qu'elle n'a pas les moyens
qu'il faut qu'elle n'a pas les moyens
non seulement financier mais technique
parce que notamment la justice ne les
pôles pas l'injustice n'est pas au
rendez vous et on sait parfaitement les
policiers dont 10 20 fois que les
délinquants attraper sont relâchés très
vite parfois pas d'hier puisque c'est la
loi et que la loi est mal faite
donc il ya ce sentiment que nous ne
sommes plus n'avons plus ce service
public fondamental et premier question
de la sécurité
si ce sentiment perdure le mythe sur la
justice se doit rassurer les français
dont je suis là en appui des loyers mais
malheureusement ça n'est pas du tout il
a su même la position inverse oui très
clairement c'est du ce n'est pas vrai il
n'y a pas du tout laxisme judiciaire
pour bien sûr on va mettre tous les
délinquants en prison
lire c'est pas moi c'est pas nous qui
l'avons décidé c'est la droite et il a
raison de parler de palais m mais on est
nous la gauche on est plutôt revenu un
an et en dessous d'un an mais pas des
gens plus en plus à son gap à la place
on va se revoir pas les entasser c'est
une humains etc
quant aux grands délinquants le ci
faisait plus que si on les laissait
jusqu'au bout ça devrait aider de bêtes
sauvages enfin il assume absolument la
politique pénale qui est menée
actuellement et il ne fait ne prend pas
ne prend pas la pression vous dire
qu'ils considéraient à prendre le partie
de l'opinion contre l'institution
il est pourri les îles et pour
l'institution contre l'opinion sur le
fondamental et pour l'opinion contre la
situation sur la boutique judiciaire
c'est le en même temps il veut être à la
fois que les magistrats et avel fois que
l'opinion mais à mon avis ils feraient
mieux de
d'inverser les d'opposition alexis donc
à votre avis ça va être difficilement
tenable comme composition non
raisonnable c'est la question c'est
celle des résultats politiques c'est
vrai que ma croix beaucoup misé sur cet
attelage malin et astucieux en apparence
dharmanand d'un côté dupond-moretti de
l'autre mais là je pense que si si si si
il y à déjà des deux pieds qui étend en
rade que le deuxième pied darmanin macro
n'ose pas allé le soutenir jusqu'au bout
ça risque de pas très bien marché
moi je crois qu'on répond pas à l'énorme
attente en matière de sécurité
simplement par la police il faut la
justice et donc il faut que le 1005
justice opère un virage une mutation il
n'est plus avocat ministre de la justice
rassure les français ça fâchera
d'ailleurs aussi certains magistrats
notamment ceux que l'on a entendu mais
ça c'est le boulot de mr la justice de
ce côté-là site une audition les
secourir les criminels on peut mettre
autant d'argent qu'on veut ils seront
toujours débordé la privatisation de la
justice ni pascal est déjà active
les magistrats quoi qu'on dise ne sont
plus autonomes souvenons nous des
exemples de récidive ces tâches de la
justice à cause d'eux à cause d'un
manque de moyens
c'est pas forcément quelque chose de
manque de moyens ça peut être également
par pas par idéologie ou on a laissé oui
oui et puis ils se sont également un
moyen qui fait des qui fait défaut c'est
une loi appropriée et vous savez que des
programmes de construction de places de
prison ont été abandonnées sous le
quinquennat précédent
et quand il a fallu du béret 13000
personnes qui étaient emprisonnés à
cause du coc vide ce qui peut se
comprendre qu'on n'a pas assez de
pasques redevenu dangereux mais enfin
105-100 peine appliquée n'est pas de
justice qu'ils soient en colère
à côté de ça je vois que du positif
vis-à-vis du crime et de la délinquance
à une vision estimable
philosophiquement qu'une vision
d'avocats qui est le mal est dans la
nature humaine soit son nom viendra
jamais à bout arrêté arrêtons de croire
et à temps de raconter aux français
qu'on va finir avec le crime et la
délinquance
toute chose qui du point de vue de
l'analyse pour tous peuvent se défendre
penser ce qu'on veut mais quand on est
en politique on dit que ça les français
ne lisent pas des hommes politiques ne
paie pas des hommes politiques pour
qu'il dise n'y a pas grand chose à faire
ce qui est un peu vis-à-vis du crime son
idée ça va être difficilement tenable je
pense en tout cas c'est votre avis criss
cross et vous nous avez donné et on vous
poser la question sur twitter est ce que
la position d'eric dupond moretti est
elle tenable peut-il tenir au sein du
gouvernement
bah vous êtes plutôt sceptique vous
répondez non majorité 54% c'est une
question c'est pas un sondage je fais un
ra tout pardon pour moi un jour quand
vous n'avez pas j'ai confondu dans
l'armée c'est une mission qui devient
maman c'est donc c'était ça je voyais
actions ordinaires et rodez rodez c'est
un parcours donc voilà donc on peut
saluer donc tous les internautes de midi
pyrénées et d'occitanie
plus généralement et bien sûr les
supporters du stade toulousain
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
vous restez sur le site du figaro en
particulier sur figaro live ce soir à 20
heures avec une soirée spéciale autour
du nouveau figaro hors série consacré à
la syrie à la 6e' 12 ans avec l'équipe
du figaro hors série pour vous parler de
l'acide également en duplex avec madame
l'ambassadeur d'italie et également des
personnes qui sont en sicile vous êtes
là donc en direct à 20h il y aura un jeu
avec des
des lots à gagner à très vite sur figaro
neige
[Musique]